[Music]
it may sound familiar to many of you
you watch a breathtaking monster movie
everything explodes
the giants fight and you suddenly start
wondering
how humongous are these monsters
actually 10 meters 100 meters
the same question crossed our mind so we
did some research for you to see what
kind of proportions the beasts of
well-known productions
actually have so sit back and get ready
for the biggest monsters in movie
history
and let us tell you there are some
surprises included
nine kong movies have already made it to
the big screen and with godzilla vs kong
the tenth one is soon to hit the
theaters
however for many years the giant gorilla
wasn't yet huge measuring just 50 meters
in most movies
since the latest film kong skull island
is set in the same universe as the 2014
released godzilla and also the joint
film has already finished
kang needed to be adapted to the giant
lizard in skull island he was already 30
meters in height but since kong was only
14 years old in the film
he has been growing considerably as we
saw in the newly released first trailer
for godzilla vs kong
now he's 95 meters in height which makes
him a real threat to the king of the
monsters as it promises a real
fight between the two giants
in 2008 cloverfield a monster movie by
jj abrams hit the big screen leaving the
audience more than just confused
for a long time no one knew exactly what
kind of monster was haunting new york
city
what's also special about the film is
that it is filmed from a handheld
camera's point of view the whole time
which is supposed to give the audience
the feeling of being up close and
personal
the monster much like the title is
called the clover
the creature originates from the
atlantic ocean where was awakened by
submarines
the success of cloverfield was followed
by two more films 2016's 10 cloverfield
lane and 2018's the cloverfield paradox
which are loosely set in the same
universe as the original
in the first part of the film series the
monster already measures a remarkable 91
meters
in the latest film adaption the
cloverfield paradox an even more massive
version of the clover appears
it is assumed that this film takes place
in a parallel universe and that it is an
adult clover being this one rises up to
above the cloud cover
on the reddit internet platform there
are speculations that the monster is
four thousand to
six thousand meters high due to the
rocket signs used by the space capsule
and the kind of clouds that can be seen
in the shot
release the kraken is certainly the most
famous phrase from the movie
clash of the titans but hardly anyone
knows that the sea monster which was
created in the film by zeus and hades
already made its screen debut in 1981
in the first film version of clash of
the titans at that time however he was
only a meager
15 meters tall in the 2010 reboot things
fortunately changed and the 91 meter
high monster now resembled more of a
godzilla with tentacles
nevertheless the kraken was turned to
stone by perseus with the head of medusa
and the enchanting andromeda
was thus saved after we already listed
khan
this monster cannot be missing of course
godzilla
the king of monsters has been making it
to the big screen again
and again since 1954. in the movies we
can marvel at various monsters of all
sizes species and with all kinds of
devastating powers
the creators usually act freely
according to the principle the more
ginormous the myriad
however there are different series and
universes which is why godzilla can
sometimes
vary extremely in size we can admire one
of the most impressive examples in the
film series by gareth edwards which has
been running since 2014.
in this american movie version godzilla
reaches a height of 108 meters
in 2016 the japanese director hiryakuano
went even further in shingoshila
by making the king of all monsters grow
to 118 meters
this seems to have triggered a
competition to see who can make godzilla
even bigger
and more powerful so in 2017 the anime
godzilla earth was released in which the
lizard reached
a height of 300 meters which is pretty
much
the height of the eiffel tower whether
the creature that will soon be appearing
godzilla vs kong will grow again
remains to be seen
when it comes to monsters the kaiju from
pacific rim cannot be omitted
and when we're talking about the king of
the monsters the king of the kaijus has
to be
included as well the so-called mega
kaiju makes his appearance in the second
part pacific rim
uprising and stands 128 meters tall
thus easily outshining the hunters
however he is not only gigantic
since he is a fusion of the three kaijus
raijin
akuja and shrekthorn he also has all
their abilities
no third part of the series has been
officially announced yet but it is
certain that at least one more part will
follow
it remains unclear however how the
directors plan to take the mega kaiju to
the next level
this one would then almost certainly
also find a place
on this list that the dragon would find
its way onto this list was certainly to
be expected
yet it is rather surprising that this
dragon comes from how to train your
dragon
and not from a fantasy epic while most
dragons in animated movies are rather
small there are also some
giant ones the bewilder beast can grow
up to 158 meters high
this is not the only thing that makes
them stand out in the film however
they can also control other dragons
provided that they are not being
controlled by others already
so far we had giant apes lizards and
krakens
one thing that's still missing in our
lineup is an oversized warm
this can be found in david lynch science
fiction classic dune from 1984
the sand worms or chai loot play a
central role in the book source of the
film
they are the ones that turn planets into
desert by absorbing water
they are also used as a means of
transportation that worship as
god or satan depending on the religion
the longest specimens reach up to 400
meters and mere 40 meters more than the
empire state building
however there is a story that tells of a
sand worm that grew up to
2778 meters long
how big the worms will be in the reboot
which has been rescheduled for release
in october remains to be seen
they will most likely have the same
proportions as the ones in the movie
from the 80s
with chronos from wrath of the titans
another character from the titan series
makes it
into a video as leader and father of
zeus and hades he faces a fierce battle
with perseus and his allies in the
sequel
in the movie he is shown as a powerful
rock and lava monster which has the size
of
a mountain he's said to be about 500
meters high exactly equal to the height
of the taipei financial center in taiwan
one of the tallest buildings
in the world whoever thought that the
following example was an alien worm
was sadly mistaken the huge monster from
star wars the empire strikes back which
almost devoured han solo and the crew of
the millennium falcon
was actually a space slug of the species
exogorth
the slugs live as seen in the film in
asteroids and are usually only about 10
or 100 meters long
however our specimen from the film is a
very rare one
believe it or not the length is
estimated at no less than 900 meters
making it one of the longest specimens
of its kind
and the most famous space smuggler of
all time also plays a role when it comes
to the most gigantic monster featured in
a video
when han and his friends had to take a
shortcut on the castle run to escape the
empire in the movie solo with star wars
story they flew straight through the
mall
the mall is a collection of black holes
in the midst of this route which they
had never flown before
they encountered the creature of the
summer vermin species
these kraken-like creatures can reach a
span of a whooping
7 500 meters thus
also the specimen from the film
fortunately
they were still able to escape by
jumping into hyperspace before the
creature got too close to the maw and
was pulled into the black holes
by this heroic jump they also managed to
do the legendary castle run in under 12
parsecs which brought not only han solo
but also the millennium falcon
to much fame well there you go
some of the biggest monsters in movie
history
did we miss one that actually belongs on
this list or do you know an even bigger
one than the sumo verminoth
then feel free to let us know in the
comments if you like this video please
give us a thumbs up
[Music]
you